alright guys i'm just gonna be real with
you i've been a huge fan of apple's
higher end ipads for years now because
of different factors like the updated
design the feature set and the
performance but now that it's been over
half a year since apple's budget ipad 9
has been released i've realized that the
10.2 inch ipad accomplishes so much for
so little honestly packing enough
features and performance for most people
out there so in this video i'm going to
highlight all of the benefits with going
with an ipad 9 instead of apple's
expensive ipad air and pro models
especially if you're budget conscious
because you can actually save quite a
lot more money than you think you can
without sacrificing an excellent and
reliable user experience no matter if
you just want to use it casually on your
couch or if you're actually trying to
replace your laptop and since nothing is
perfect in this world i'll also be
covering the downsides that you
absolutely must know if you're going to
be going with the budget ipad instead of
one of the more expensive models so be
sure to stick through to the end of this
video so you don't miss out on anything
now one of the main reasons people go
for the more expensive ipads is the
higher level of performance and that's
exactly what you get with the m1 chip in
both the ipad air and the pro but i've
actually been shocked by how well the
a13 ship in the ipad 9 performs first of
all if you just look at the benchmarks
you'd expect there to be a noticeable
difference in day-to-day use between the
a13 chip and the m1 in the ipad air
that's literally two to three times
faster in terms of cpu and gpu
performance but in reality you can
hardly tell a difference while swiping
through the home screen using common
apps or browsing the web which goes to
show how impressive the a13 really is
but what shocked me the most was the
gaming performance when i was getting a
solid 60 fps in a bunch of different
games like call of duty mobile pokemon
unite and league of legends wild rift
which is the exact performance i was
getting on the m1 ipad air which means
that all of the extra horsepower is
going to waste it even played the most
demanding ipad game out there gentian
impact at completely maxed out graphics
settings and it performed impressively
well with minimal frame drops and this
to me is a big deal because the previous
ipad 8 that came with the old a12 chip
performed quite a bit worse so this new
ipad 9 is the first 10.2 inch budget
model that totally kills it in terms of
gaming performance and of course it's
not perfect because it still uses the
legacy design with the touch id home
button on the front instead of a fully
redesigned edge to edge display like on
the more expensive ipads but for 310
dollars right now on amazon you simply
can't beat the value that you're getting
because it finally packs a few very
important changes that apple has been
holding off on for years first of all
the budget ipad has come with only 32
gigs of storage ever since the 5th
generation ipad that was released in
2017
for
329
but now apple has finally doubled the
storage for the same 329 dollars which
is actually incredible if you consider
inflation spiking over the past five
years not only that but the budget ipad
has come with a 1.2 megapixel selfie
camera ever since the ipad 4 was
released in 2012
so for the first time in literally a
decade apple has upgraded the selfie
camera to a new 12 megapixel ultra wide
camera with 10 times the megapixels and
yes it's exactly the same selfie camera
that comes on apple's most expensive
ipad pro so based on those three changes
the snappy a13 chip the doubling of
storage and the new selfie camera i'd
say that this is the best update the
budget ipad has ever seen in terms of
value and i'm actually shocked that
apple kept the price unchanged with all
of this value added to it and that's
actually not the only difference because
with this year's ipad 9 apple upgraded
the display to support true tone which i
absolutely love and use on all of my
apple products including my iphone and
my macbook pro and they also improved
the video camera quality allowing
extended dynamic range as well as 1080p
recording at up to 60 fps but getting
back to the main point of this video the
most important reason why it makes sense
to go for the budget ipad 9 compared to
the ipad air and the pro is that you not
only save a huge amount of money up
front on the ipad purchase itself but
you also continue to save more cash as
you purchase more accessories for
example if you want an apple pencil with
the ipad air or the pro you can only buy
the second gen apple pencil which costs
a whopping 129 dollars but with the
budget ipad 9 you have the option of
buying the logitech crayon with full
stylus support for only 50 right now on
amazon which is a massive savings of 79
bucks but going even further one of the
main reasons why people buy the more
expensive ipad air in pro is because
they come with support for those awesome
keyboard cases with built-in track pads
like apple's magic keyboard case for a
huge 300
or the less expensive alternative the
logitech folio touch which also has full
trackpad support and a full row of
function keys for basically 145 to 155
bucks but what a lot of people don't
know is that you can get basically the
same thing on the ipad 9 since it also
comes with the smart connector but the
logitech combo touch is actually even
less expensive and it comes with an
apple pencil holder so you don't lose it
and as far as the usability and
experience it's excellent with zero
latency and it supports all of apple's
trackpad gestures and keyboard shortcuts
since logitech is the only third-party
company that has full access to apple
smart connector and custom apis but the
main point i want to make is that if you
want a full ipad setup with a pencil and
a trackpad keyboard case included you're
only spending 503
with the budget ipad 9 if you use the
amazon links in the pin comment below
instead of
834 dollars for the ipad air and a
massive
1033 dollars for the ipad pro more than
twice the price as the ipad 9 setup so
for 503 dollars you've got a capable
ipad that you can do basically anything
you want with from general web browsing
watching youtube or streaming movies and
shows playing some of the best games at
a solid 60 fps sketching or taking notes
with a pencil and of course using it
like a laptop with full trackpad support
for small business work or anything else
but of course it still has its problems
that you need to be aware of if you're
gonna be buying this setup like the
display glass being non-laminated so it
isn't nearly as high quality as the
other ipads it of course has the old
design with a home button and square
display which doesn't look as good the
specs are somewhat outdated compared to
the others like the older bluetooth spec
and it has the older chip and finally it
still comes with a lightning port
compared to the other ipads which all
come with usbc but if you can look past
those few things and you just need a
basic ipad for a great price i think
that this one is by far the best bang
for the buck and it gets a lot more
accomplished than many people expect so
hopefully you enjoyed this review and if
you did go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and definitely check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]